Speaker 1: If you want to see one statistic.
That really exposes the United States as a
growing dystopian hellscape of anti-intellectual
ism and non thinking.
It is this statistic in the last three polls,
Herschel Walker is leading Raphael Warnock.
Now, if you're wondering who these people
are, I will remind you.
Herschel Walker is the Republican Senate nominee
in Georgia.
Right now.
That seat is held by Raphael Warnock.
Raphael Warnock is an intelligent, thinking,
nuanced elected official who, whether you
agree with him or not on any individual policy,
clearly has the interests of Georgia's residents
as his priority and can engage with others
in clear and productive ways where you understand
what he thinks and you can talk substantively
about issues.
Herschel Walker is a former football player
who can barely speak coherently, can't explain
his views about any issue and is.
Epitomizing the worst of the non thinking
MAGA movement.
And yes, in recent polls Walker has taken
a lead.
If we look at the last three polls in that
race, the Insider Advantage poll has Walker
plus three.
The Emerson poll has Walker plus two and the
Trafalgar Poll has Walker plus one.
Those are the last three polls.
We have two of them from August and one from
September.
This is a man who cannot express himself.
This is a man who cannot explain why he believes
what he believes on any issue.
And there are enough people in Georgia seemingly
willing to vote for him that he might actually
take out incumbent Senator Raphael Warnock.
Many of you have written to me and you said,
David, you know, it was bad when Bush beat
Gore and it was bad when Trump beat Hillary,
and it was bad when the country elected Marjorie
Taylor.
GREENE And on and on.
But there is something I can't put my finger
on.
If the country elects Walker over Warnock,
I'm getting the hell out of here.
And I don't know that people are literally
meaning that.
Often when people say, I'll move to Canada,
they don't really mean it.
It's also really difficult to move to Canada.
Just as a reminder, this is what we're talking
about when we talk about Herschel Walker.
Here is Walker.
Asked why he hasn't agreed to debate Warnock.
It's a very strange answer.
Herschel.
Speaker 2: Senator Raphael Warnock wants to
debate you.
You didn't debate during the primaries where
you walked away with 68% of the Republican
votes.
Why won't you commit to a debate?
Well, first of all, Senator, one, I have nothing
else to talk about.
He don't want to talk about the high gas prices.
You don't want to talk about high groceries.
I've told him many times I'm ready to debate
him any time, any day.
I just want to make it for the fans, not about
a political party or about some media and
for the fans.
Speaker 1: These are elected officials or
want to be elected officials.
Wow.
Here is the same Herschel Walker asked by
CNN reporter Monroe Rogers should there be
new laws in the wake of the latest shooting.
Speaker 2: Of Rogers on CNN?
Are you supporting new gun laws in the wake
of these tensions?
Should you support new gun laws?
In the wake of what I to do, what I do is
bring in and everything I like to see it,
you know.
Speaker 1: I like to see it and everything
and stuff.
And then famous famously, Herschel Walker
weighing in on his plan for dealing with shootings
through social media.
Speaker 2: See, there is a person will in
that weapon, you know, Kane kill Abel, you
know, and you that's a problem that we have.
And I said, what we need to do is look into
how we can stop those things.
You know, he talked about doing a disinformation.
What about getting a department that can look
at young men as looking at women?
They're looking at the social media.
What about when they're looking?
Speaker 1: We need a department looking at
young men that's looking at women, that's
looking at social media.
He is now leading in the three recent polls.
This is scary as hell.
Scary as hell.
Let me know what you think will ultimately
happen in that race.
Monday, 919 is our next one day membership
drive.
If you've been thinking about getting a membership,
but you'd like to get a massive, humiliatingly
huge discount.
Humiliating to me.
Let's be honest.
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com
Monday morning you'll get an email telling
you exactly how to take advantage of this
great discount.
919 is the day.